Here is my implementation of twiddle. This
is a routine that you can keep this way for
many, many different applications. All it
requires is a way to evaluate something that
depends on the parameters and gives you a
single arrow that you would like to minimize.
We have three parameters in total, I set the
parameters themselves to zero, but the deltas
to one and it’s just the counter, its unimportant.
If the sum of D params is still larger than our
tolerance which we initially have as 0.001 and they go through all
the parameter sequentially I increment that
by D params, find out what the arrow is if
the arrow is better than our best arrow,
which I initialize with the initial arrow
and I keep the best arrow and I even increment
D params. Otherwise, I try the other direction.
One, find out the arrow, if that succeeds,
I keep it, I increment D params. And here is
my last case, I didn’t succeed, so going to
set it back to the old parameter vector and
decrease my D params by 0.9. I increase my
counter, here is my little print out command
for debugging and I will turn the parameter
vector. So it will be comingout of the print
vectors over here and play with this a little more
. If I want twiddle, compute the best parameters
and then calculate the error using these
parameters and print out the parameters
along with the arrow, I get a parameter vector
and I get an arrow that’s basically zero.
Now let’s switch off the integral term.
And I can do this with a little trick.
I just set D params number two, which is the
final one to 0.0 as if I’ve already learned the
integral term. When I run this, I get a zero
integral term, but the arrow that’s somewhat
larger than the final arrow, the desired. And
that’s because the integral term is really
required to drive the arrow, down to zero. Let’s
also remove the D term and see what happens
and the result is a really large arrow,
0.55. That large arrow, sustains even if
I remove the over drift by commenting
it out. You still get an arrow, of 0.10 if
it does have a proportional controller, whereas
if I add in the differential parameter again,
by removing the D param 1 command the
0.103 goes down to 5.7 to the minus 11,
which is practically zero. So you can see
the importance of the D term for driving
the arrow, down to zero, in the case without
drift and for the integral term in cases for
vowels with a systematic bias. You play
a little bit more with this code for the
homework assignment. But this is it for now.